Seth weathers uh launched this beer
company about a month and a half ago at
this point and at this point in my life
I do nothing but
um
manage a beer company so it's taken off
we we put out a video an ad that I think
probably a lot of you your viewers have
seen because you played it out there
yeah you put out the day we launched it
and um on my Twitter account alone I
think we have over 46 million views
which is nuts because I don't have some
huge Twitter account
um and it's just continued to get
traction you know I think overall online
between all the different places that's
been placed we're probably about 100
million views like you don't start a
beer company and have that kind of brand
ID it's it's wild yeah it's actually
really I'm not a big beer guy I like
Yingling I like this yeah yeah it's a
solid beer you know it's not you know
this came out of the Bud Light
controversy but I do want to let people
know this is not a Bud Light knockoff
because I I don't think Bud likes is a
real beer Down Beer by the way they were
actually sued and lost millions of
dollars for literally watering down
their beer in the past